[Music]
a star-powered squad that controls its
own destiny
a future hall of fame players the coach
steering the ship
expectations are at an all-time high and
they wouldn't want it
any other way this is the story of the
2020
21 brooklyn nets the season began with
the welcome return of kd
the two-time nba champion and 10-time
all-star hadn't played in a year and a
half since his achilles injury
the anticipation around him enough to
drew could be put to rest
as the new era of nets basketball
finally arrived
they went from being swept in the first
round just four months prior to
contenders
with some of the best in the league
little did we know referring to them as
favorites
would only serve as the first phase of
expectations
they suffered a few head scratching l's
along the way but that
is to be expected on the flip they took
care of some of the best in the league
showing just the caliber team they are
some of those big w's were without
number 11
who made headlines for stepping away
from the squad
irving missed seven games and received a
50 000
fine after a video of him at a birthday
party surfaced
when he returned he addressed the matter
and then went on the floor
to do what he does best show out
while irving was out the nets would send
shockwaves through the league
just two weeks into the new year they
traded for eight-time all-star
three-time scoring champ and king of the
step back mr james harden
reuniting the bearded one with his okc
buddy for way back when
and assembling a devastating trio of
offensive firepower
two months later they would sign blake
griffin and then lamarcus aldridge
yet again producing shockwaves
throughout the league and reactions of
all kinds
from fans they managed to stride through
it all
and hold a top c position a season of
the unexpected
a revolving door of lineup changes
injuries and
even a retirement the only constant
kd up to his usual twitter activities
as well as the conversations surrounding
them and those men in purple and gold
out in los angeles a matchup we will
witness just twice during the season
with key players missing each time but
that nevertheless
gave us a taste of what could be in june
the opportunity has arrived the playoffs
are here
some want to see them fail others want
to see them shine
none of it matters now there are 16 wins
away from
glory and their first nba title
expectations will not waver for this
team they don't get a chance to figure
it out
they must win and win now because legacy
hangs in the balance
with every triple they take as a great
author once put it
a legacy is etched into the minds of
others
and the stories they share about you